Thank you so much for joining.
I'm Elizabeth Garlow.
I'm a senior fellow with the new practice lab at New America.
And last November, New America, in partnership with the Biden administration, hosted a gathering
on policy design and implementation for equitable well-being.
This was on the heels of a design sprint that we did with the Census Bureau and the Departments
of Commerce and Treasury through an initiative called the Opportunity Project to develop
tools that could help with the design and implementation of well-being measures.
So throughout these gatherings and that sprint, we've cultivated this unlikely cross-section
of policymakers, social and grassroots movement leaders across the U.S.
We're coming together to really deep dive on data measurement framework and narrative
building considerations to advance equitable well-being.
So a group of participants, many of you are here today, have shared their interest in
continued learning and exchange.
And that is the purpose of our time together today.
So as we open up, I'd like to ask two of my co-hosts to quickly introduce themselves,
Tony Gadati and Amanda Janou.
I'll turn it over to you.
My name is Tony Gadati and I'm a JHD fellow at Harvard University's Edmund and Lily Safra
Center for Ethics.
The U.S. Health and Democracy Impact Initiative is a partnership between researchers, policymakers
and stakeholders working to deliver ethics-based, impactful and timely solutions to urgent public
problems.
We're so glad to be with you and co-sponsor this event because we know that meaningful
prioritization of well-being and quality of life requires a whole-of-government approach
to learning and policymaking.
I look forward to hearing the discussions in today's webinar.
Amanda, over to you.
Hi, good morning, everyone.
My name is Amanda Janou and I work as the economics and policy lead for the Well-being
Economy Alliance, or WE ALL, which is a global movement of actors who recognize that economic
growth accompanied by worsening social and environmental outcomes really can't be considered
success.
But that turning things around is going to require us to change the way we think, the
way we act, and really critically the way we measure success.
And a really important example in this movement is the well-being economy governments who
have all moved beyond GDP to develop holistic well-being frameworks and indicators that
begin to evaluate their societal progress by their level of social and ecological well-being.
And Canada's quality of life framework is one of my personal favorites as they not only
are measuring dimensions such as social connection and a sense of meaning and purpose, which
especially this week we've heard is so critically urgent to begin looking more at within our
own country here in the United States.
But I'm just really excited that they'll be able to share a bit about their vision and
learnings with our U.S. government here as well.
And I just want to also share for anybody who's interested in learning more about the
well-being economy government's work, I'm going to post it in the chat.
They're hosting a gathering next month in Iceland where they're going to be diving into
more discussions around well-being measurements, budgeting systems, and many other topics.
Thank you so much, Amanda.
So welcome to all of you.
We have an amazing core group of U.S. federal policymakers, state and local policy leaders,
and others who are really committed to well-being policy.
And then we have these incredible colleagues in Canada who've been developing and spearheading
early implementation of their quality of life framework, as Amanda just shared.
So before we hear from them, I'd just like to turn it over to Rear Admiral Paul Reed,
the Deputy Assistant Secretary for Health at the U.S. Department of Health and Human
Services.
Admiral Reed and his colleague, Aaron McDonald, and their team are spearheading the U.S.
Equitable Long-Term Recovery and Resilience Initiative, which is this incredible government-wide
approach to improve well-being and long-term resilience in the U.S.
So I'll turn it over to Admiral Reed.
Thank you, Elizabeth.
I'm just going to apologize upfront for my voice battling through a bit of laryngitis,
but I am very happy to be here today and I'm thrilled that this meeting is occurring,
particularly at this point in time.
I consider it a bit of non-randomness that we're having this convening because I see
a convergence of a whole bunch of activities occurring.
And to be able to be in conversation with our Canadian colleagues on the work that they
have historically done and continue to do is just incredibly informative at this moment
for us to consider moving forward in a number of different ways.
From where I sit as the Director of the Office of Disease Prevention and Health Promotion
within HHS, where we house our Hallmark program, Healthy People 2030, and have housed it
for over 40 years, I think speaking from that position and that perspective, we've seen
a very natural evolution over four decades and then some in the way in which healthy
people entertains upstream factors, social determinants, and a broader perspective, a
broader lens towards measuring health and now well-being.
And we see that trajectory continuing into the next iteration.
We're looking in the next couple of years to starting the process for developing Healthy
People 2040.
And part of that timeliness of this conversation is how this dialogue can be informative into
the next steps of developing Healthy People 2040.
That's just one of those convergences, as I mentioned.
The other is, as Elizabeth mentioned, I've had the pleasure of being an Executive Shepard,
if you will, for the Equitable Long-Terming Recovery and Resilience Plan, which now has
a three-year history to it, born of the early stages of the pandemic response, when very
difficult questions were asked of a cohort within the whole-of-government response
framework around what the implications of the pandemic were going to mean for the federal
government and for the whole of society, particularly entertaining a very complicated
question, which is, what does the federal government need to do in the long term as we
come through the pandemic response, through the recovery, and look to a long-term future in
building out resilience for the nation, building to a higher level of resilience in this
country than we knew in 2019?
A very profound question with a lot of ramifications, not only for the federal government,
but also for the way in which the federal government interacts with the whole of society.
And we've been doing a great deal of work in that space, as Elizabeth alluded to, and as
Erin will speak to a bit, I think, as well in our conversations later this hour.
We believe the framework that the Canadians have developed and are utilizing ought to be
very informative into that process as well.
And we believe also, I'll speak for myself, I firmly believe that the work we're doing to
develop a measurement strategy around resilience and all of its components is also going to be
complementary to the next iteration of the Health and People 2040, and the way in which we
look to expand on well-being as a concept and a measurement strategy around that as well.
So with those remarks, I'll be quiet.
My voice is probably going to force me to be anyway, and I'm going to get out of a way of
great conversation. But I very much appreciate everybody being here, especially to hear from
our Canadian colleagues. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Admiral Reed, and we heard you loud and clear even through the laryngitis.
So thank you for that.
So I'm excited to turn it over to our colleagues in Canada who will share for about 20 minutes some
background on their work with the Quality of Life Framework, and then we'll turn it over to Erin
McDonald within HHS and the lead on the Equitable Long-Term Recovery and Resilience Plan to share
some questions with our guests.
So, Harry Walansky, I will start with you first.
If you could please introduce yourself and then share some of your presentation, we would
be delighted. Thank you so much.
Thanks for the introduction.
So delighted to be here to hear about the momentum that's coalescing together in different
sort of parts of society.
So not just within government, but civil society and all of that.
I think that really mirrors our experience here in Canada.
My name is Carrie Walansky.
I come to you with two hats to talk about one of my very favorite topics, which is the
story of origin of Canada's Quality of Life Framework.
I have two hats because at the beginning of the development of Canada's Quality of Life
Framework, I was the director responsible from a policy standpoint of that work in the
Department of Finance, so tied into the budget process.
I've now moved to Statistics Canada, which is responsible for the program of Quality of
Life Statistics. So very much keen on taking this work to that sort of next level.
So I'm going to be talking to you from both of those hats because a lot of your questions
have talked about sort of how did we get here.
So I'm going to start with almost my kind of finance voice and then shift into Statistics
Canada. So if you wouldn't mind displaying the slides, we can go straight to the second
one. So in distilling the international conversation in this space, there's such a
clear convergence of the momentum around these three things, these three thematic areas.
So people call it different things, could be quality of life, could be well-being, could
be the social determinants of health, could be the multidimensional aspects of poverty.
There are different ways into this conversation.
But the core idea there is we need to be multidimensional and holistic and look at how
the pieces fit together in terms of social, economic and environmental considerations.
So that's sort of a thematic lens.
But there's also this issue of equality, distributions, differences in outcomes for
different groups and how you reflect that story.
And then there's this sort of sustainability and resilience.
So what does this all look like in terms of the trajectory and pathway we're on?
What are the implications of our decisions today?
What are the long term impacts and considerations?
And sometimes sustainability gets wrapped into a conversation about climate change,
which is obviously fundamentally important to the conversation about sustainability.
But our frame for sustainability is broader than that.
It's also about a life course approach to education and learning.
It's about prevention and health and that sort of thing.
So next slide, please.
So this is I refer to this a moment ago, our process steps in our story of origin.
We had direction from the prime minister to the minister for middle class prosperity
and associate minister of finance at the time in his mandate letter at the beginning
of the twenty nineteen mandate to lead work directly referencing work internationally
by New Zealand and Scotland on integrating quality of life measurements better into the
budgeting and policy development process.
And so we'll talk a bit more about the process of how we got to the release and budget
2021 of our framework and our approach to implementing in the in the budget process
in budget 20. Sorry.
And in the next mandate in twenty twenty one, the minister for middle class prosperity
became the president of the Treasury Board and this work came with her.
So my colleague Stephanie will talk about the role that the Treasury Board that supports
her now plays in the implementation and leadership of this work government wide.
But interestingly, the mandate letters which go from the prime minister, all ministers
in the cabinet, all include this reference to integrating quality of life considerations
into their decision making processes.
So it's no longer just the responsibility of one minister.
It's the responsibility of all ministers in cabinet to think about this alongside a
practice. We have the longstanding practice to think about gender based analysis plus
the plus being a broad range of other diversity considerations.
And then with my stat can hat, we launched our quality of life hub in March twenty twenty
two, which is the sort of public facing mechanism by which we bring together the measurement
of the indicators and the framework that was launched in budget twenty twenty one.
So next slide, please.
Here it is. This is our framework and there's a lot going on here.
But let me tell you about the architecture, which is actually deceptively simple.
We worked hard to do the hard work to keep things simple.
So it's got these five domains.
And if you think back to the one, two, three in that first slide, the five domains are
our way of trying to get at the multidimensional aspects of well-being.
So prosperity, which includes housing, health, poverty, that sort of thing, health, which
includes mental health as well as the care system and a positive mental health frame,
importantly, society, which includes things like relationships to your community, to
friends and family, time use, that sort of thing, environment, which includes the air
quality and water quality. So how is your environment impacting humans?
But also things like conservation and climate change.
And is our environment healthy to keep sustaining us?
And then good governance, which has, for example, trusted institutions, crime and safety,
discrimination, human rights, that sort of thing.
So we have the five domains of our framework.
And then if you think again back to that one, two, three, we have these two crosscutting
lenses. So if that was one, the domains are one and they're supported by a set of 84
indicators. Two is this crosscutting lens on fairness and inclusion.
So that is that gender based analysis plus practice of looking at each of the indicators,
not just as a national average, but as a distributional picture.
So what's happening underneath that are groups falling behind, et cetera.
Then we also have a crosscutting sustainability and resilience lens.
And that one is meant to get at that long term dimensions.
And I'll be really interested, to be honest, to hear where your work goes on resilience.
I think our framework is probably in its infancy on that element.
It's there. People are asked to think about it in their work.
It's not fully developed.
Next slide, please.
So in terms of the development of the framework, you had mentioned your
intersectoral collaboration, that was very and the whole of government focus, very
relevant for us as well.
We had an interdepartmental group, the deputy minister of finance tasked his
colleagues to form an assistant deputy minister group that met quite regularly
through the period of development of the framework.
And the idea there was to make sure that we were reflecting the existing frameworks
that already were there, the key indicators, the departments were already working
towards that sort of thing, as well as the subject matter expertise being fairly broad.
So one of the things we kicked off with was a mapping exercise where we looked at all
the other frameworks.
So, for example, the Canadian indicator for the framework for the sustainable
development goals, which indicators were they tracking?
And we tried to simplify and distill what we were looking at in terms of
the multitude of frameworks that exist across the government into these sort of
overarching themes that were underpinned by this evidence base globally on life
satisfaction evaluations.
Canada is highly federated and unlike any work I've been involved in, frankly, as
part of the federal government before, this framework goes much beyond the scope of our
responsibilities.
So we did not limit, we used that global evidence base to anchor us in what we
thought we should be measuring rather than starting from what we were doing, proving
it was working. And so that is a feature that's new.
And it makes this kind of a monitoring framework versus, for example, you know, you
could set targets off the back of your monitoring, but there's not targets and
activities clustered against each of these each of these indicators.
We're monitoring things that government may have little to do with in order to see
how Canadians are doing.
Also important in the Canadian context, we're having we're in the process of
renegotiating around the Crown Indigenous relations and also reconciliation.
And so we had conversations with national Indigenous organizations, many of whom have
longstanding wisdom to offer in terms of holistic thinking, asset based framing and
sustainability and long term thinking.
You don't see it reflected right now in the framework architecture because our
decision to support what they were saying was to invest in Indigenous led
framework development and data sovereignty.
So there's investments that came at Budget 2021 in Indigenous data governance.
I do hope that over time that this work will sort of cross pollinate again.
And we have sort of bookmarked that the framework remains evergreen to allow for
that to happen. I mentioned the evidence base, so I won't go that into that again,
just to say that we did talk to it was covid times, we talked to so many experts
in this space were so grateful for their contributions and it was surprising extent
to which even traditional economic stakeholders were along for the ride.
And there was sort of focus on addressing data gaps, this distributional
considerations, the long term perspective that you see represented in the
framework. Next slide, please.
I want to spend a second here because you asked about this idea of ground
truthing. That's new language for me, but we did do this interesting exercise on
public opinion research. And this was in August 2020, sorry, 2020.
So it was early in the pandemic. People were still home and largely.
And it was really interesting. It was one of the most interesting public opinion
research panels the public opinion researchers had ever done because people
were so reflective at that time about what was changing and what it meant for them
and really sort of back to basic truth and principles about what matters.
So these really basic things, physical health, financial security, mental health,
personal safety, and there was a broad support for thinking about government
moving beyond GDP. Next slide, please.
So now I'm going to briefly switch over to my stat can hat.
Say we launched this hub. I'd love for you to check it out.
It's it's I'll make sure somehow I haven't figured out the mechanism, but I'll
make sure you have a link to it so that you can go and explore what's there.
It's still a work in progress. It will always be.
But what it does is it provides the data that we have.
So it pulls together from across Statistics Canada and other data providers,
all of the supporting data and evidence underneath each of those indicators and
related research so that you can access it in sort of a one stop place.
We want to work on its functionality, that sort of thing.
But what it's giving you is, you know, you know, you can go there and get the most
recent data that's available on any of those indicators.
We also have a program to actively look at data gaps and filling data gaps.
And so that could be gaps where we've collected something.
So we don't collect something at all.
It could be gaps where we collect something, but it's, you know, every five years.
So timeliness is the issue.
Could be gaps where we collect something, but it's not disaggregatable
in the way that we'd like to see in terms of the subpopulation
just difference differences, or it could be that it's collected,
but just not published.
So we've been addressing all of those piece by piece.
That's our work program.
So next slide, please.
I want to point to this, we're nearly done, but I want to point to this
as an example of a data gap that we've filled.
This is based on the UK's measure of sense of meaning and purpose.
We adopted their measure.
We think that international standardization is really valuable to build traction
and consensus around these indicators.
And so this is data that was never collected in Canada
before the quality of life framework.
And so it tells you about the distribution regionally of sense of meaning and purpose.
And there's a age split here, age and gender split
that I think is interesting on the bottom.
You can see the lower levels of sense and meaning purpose
around younger men than women, for example.
So, you know, not declaring on what should happen or if anything, as a result of that.
But it's just an interesting example of the sorts of signals
you can see from this monitoring work.
So last slide, I just want to take a moment to talk about
sort of what we're seeing.
One indicator, so it's not going to be a surprise to anybody
that people are feeling the pinch of inflation.
This is a conversation everyone's well familiar with.
But I think to make the point about objective and subjective indicators
and how they can complement one another, if you look at inflation trends,
the growth in inflation starts to slow at the same time
as people start to report having more and more difficulty paying their bills.
So if you look at these three lines, the red line is people who are having
who are finding it easy to pay their bills.
And you can see that big dip in that last quarter, which is Q4 of 2022.
So the winter last winter, you can see that big drop.
So you can see it trending down and then it dropping.
And conversely, the blue line is.
Sorry, I got that backwards.
Red is the easy or very easy, and that's coming down and very difficult
is the blue and it's coming up.
So more people are finding it much harder.
You can see that crossover effect.
So that's just an example of why it's interesting and relevant
to monitor how people experiencing this economic trend
versus just the economic trend itself,
because that's the same time when people started to talk about
the rate of growth slowing and things effectively getting better.
So I'm going to wrap there and hand over to my colleague, Stephanie.
Hello.
So my name is Stephanie Gann and I'm a director of
what he called Frameworks Integration.
It's my team, then, that oversees the implementation of Quality of Life.
The aim is to get it across the decision making cycle.
But we'll get we'll we'll talk about that in some detail in just a moment.
It is that Carrie, with her two hats, is able to cover off
kind of two aspects of the journey.
The one that I will focus on is about how to make it
so that this framework is understood for what it can do
with the tools that we have where I am in the Chartered Board Secretariat.
So could I ask for a little bit more detail on how to make it
in the Chartered Board Secretariat?
So could I ask for my objective projected as possible?
Thank you very much.
So let's go to slide two, actually.
So we understood that
once you have the framework, the quality of life data in mind,
what you naturally will progress to in terms of topics of interest is,
yeah, how how is it going in our story is one about implementation
and kind of what it is taking and what it will take to have
what everyone is interested in, which is the impacts,
the actual positive impacts on quality of life.
And for here, for us, that means the well-being
and quality of life of Canadians. Next slide, please.
So this might be a curious place to start,
although it might be something that's not too
unfamiliar to kind of the policy practitioners.
When we talk implementation in government,
an essential piece of that is looking at the kind of supporting
infrastructure, the nuts and bolts of the inside plumbing
for how decision making happens.
You can't just have a direct impact on on outcomes
without thinking through how it is that decisions are made and how you get there.
And so here what you have is the decision making process as we see it.
The ambition is to see it so that the quality of life framework,
its data and the approach is actually applied at every one of these steps.
So where do we start?
It's with the agenda that the government sets
and the priority is that they identify.
There are a number of different mechanisms by which this occurs.
And so you have some that are listed here.
For instance, the government will kick off every new session of parliament
with a speech from the throne.
There are mandate letters that carry referred to,
which is how the prime minister communicates specific commitments
and expectations to his or her cabinet ministers.
It's with that agenda, then, that the minister of finance
identifies budget priorities based on input from from from all ministers.
This is an important piece
of the quality of life puzzle in that, yes, as much as
as much as we at the Charter Board Secretariat
are responsible for implementing quality of life.
It was by virtue of the mandate letters that this responsibility was clarified
to be that of all ministers is just here at TBS that we need to be supporting them
in their duties.
So what we what we'll get to in just a moment
is about how quality of life is reflected in the budget process.
Once you have your budget priorities,
there is a step of going to cabinet for for discussions
and for outstanding policy authorities.
It's from there that there is a little bit of a handoff to my department.
It's that as the as a TBS, we are secretariat
to the executive cabinet committee known as Treasury Board.
It has a particular role in vetting implementation proposals
of things that have funding, things that have policy authorities.
It's here that we have a number of levers
to make things happen
before things hit the ground running with ministers and departments
are rolling out policies in implementation and monitoring and evaluating them.
So that is the overview of kind of the steps
where we hope to integrate quality of life into the process.
But there is something about how introducing new initiatives,
new ways of thinking, even if they make sense,
how it really just cannot be done all at once.
There are hats, there are leads,
and there is the importance of coordinating.
So I think in this space, even from the government perspective,
where you're supposed to be the strong suit is planning
and making plans and making plans to plan.
But there is a patchiness to it.
I think of introducing new things, even if they matter,
even if they can make a difference.
So there's a little bit of a story of that that we'll look at a little bit
a little bit more. Can I get to the next slide, please?
So what you would have seen in the decision making process
is a number of steps that have
the central agencies or government having in our government
having share, having some responsibility for.
So that's the Preview Council Office that oversees the cabinet process.
It's the department that supports the prime minister.
They are a very important partner for for us.
It is really, though, kind of
finances efforts in implementing quality of life and our efforts as TBS.
That will be the focus here.
But it is that
you'll you'll see that in different jurisdictions,
there normally is the appreciation for how quality of life as a policy
lead needs to reside centrally.
There are some things you give up when you have it somewhere different in
health, let's say,
or in a social department where, let's say,
the work on well-being is significantly more advanced.
You really do give up some some levers, but that is the choice that that you can
that you can make.
There are sometimes decisions to house the lead in
a version of the PCO.
We as you all heard and as we'll talk about more in the next slide,
I can make the choice of putting it in the Treasury or a department of finance.
That creates a certain thank you very much for that.
That creates a certain
foundation and puts you on a certain path.
I don't think there's consensus over
what is what is the best choice.
There has to be some appreciation for where a particular jurisdiction is at
and what levers are available.
Side note.
That we have a Treasury Board secretary, it's a bit weird
to to to lots of lots of partners,
and that's something that we that has advantages and disadvantages.
But more concretely, when we're talking about quality of life implementation, then
and in in budgeting, which is where we kicked it off under
under Carey's work, in fact,
what we're talking about is
in in the course of identity, identifying budget priorities.
Normally, it's the case that the minister of finance will actually have a call out
call up for budget requests from from the rest of cabinet ministers.
And there's a very well defined process for this
and a very particular form that proposals for budget measures takes.
And this becomes really quite important in holding the purse strings.
The Department of Finance is able to set a certain standard
for the kind of information required for budget measures.
And since twenty twenty one, this has included the identification
of expected impacts on quality of life indicators.
This means that at the development of these measures,
this is something that has to be thought about and considered
with some conscientiousness.
So it is that since a budget twenty twenty one,
budgets have been published with an impacts report that summarizes
these impacts on a measure by measure basis.
Now, this ends up being very important for TBS.
Next slide, please.
So it was in late twenty twenty one that the handoff process happened.
So it was now that quality of life was in the budgeting process.
How do we roll it out more generally?
So it's that if we go back, so not actually go back in the deck.
But if you can remember in the decision making process,
when we're at implementation, this is where actually TBS has
quite a significant role.
It is that as in providing support to Treasury Board, again, that statutory
cabinet committee,
it it has a function as the government's management board
and ensures that implementation plans of things that are funded
and have appropriate policy cover are consistent with the government's
TV policy suite, one of which is the policy on results.
So at TBS, it's that
in this capacity, we have a number of tools to establish expected outcomes
for deputy ministers, expectations for management practices
and policies for new program designs, but also for the existing spending base.
And this is pretty important for the kind of change
that we want to see incorporating quality of life into government work.
So these implementation proposals that end up being presented
to the Treasury Board, well, we are wanting
these proposals have a number of components that are required,
including details on program design,
implementation costs, but also expected results.
Importantly, funds approved through budget just cannot be accessed
without approval of of the Treasury Board.
And that is a lever that we that we use and intend to use
with a little bit more vigor.
Going ahead, we are looking at the integration,
the better integration of quality of life data into these proposals,
consideration of the framework in plans for evaluation and performance
measurement, alignment of government program outcomes
with quality of life indicators.
And I would say that TBS also has a very important role
in government wide reporting.
Federal departments prepare an annual plan,
annual reports, rather, on their plans and results achieved.
And the president of the Treasury Board
tables these reports in parliament.
It's that the TBS develops requirements for these plans
and guidance for how to meet them.
And on the reporting front, we're looking at options for how to introduce
something like a common reporting frame on quality of life
that can help shape departmental narratives
in the interest of clarity and transparency to Canadians
and parliamentarians on what we're doing on quality of life.
Because, in fact, that's where more minutes, just a couple of hours.
And then we'll turn to questions.
Sorry, I will try to wrap that up then.
So next slide, please.
So I think maybe I'll tie it up together by saying
it is in it might feel as though
TBS in the role of implementation might feel as though it's inside baseball.
But it is that if you don't get some of these processes and steps in place,
you're kind of shooting darts in in the in the dark.
What matters here is the results at the end.
That is how the approach survives.
That's how you show that it has value.
But on the way there, there are a number of things that have to come into play.
There is a tremendous amount of coronations I mentioned among central agencies,
but also with the departmental community as well.
Quality of life did not show up on the scene, a blank slate.
There was a lot that was going on previously
that was quite well aligned with well-being work.
And it's really important that we acknowledge this
to be able to have the partners to move ahead together.
None of what we're proposing here is trivial.
It's not a checklist.
And it actually requires building some foundational blocks,
including capacity and training and perhaps recruiting differently
for the kind of perspectives we want to see reflected in policy work going ahead.
Kerry had mentioned how the quality of life framework is not just about leavers
and outcomes of the federal government controls.
And for that reason, our engagement with the outer
the outside community is extremely important to say nothing of how it is
that all this work is premised on this idea that Canadians see themselves
in their framework, agree and support that we have identified
the things that that matter.
And for the fact that the work in the framework is evergreen means that that exchange
and of information and feedback is, I think, a crucial piece.
So to tie it all up, maybe I would say that
engagement opportunities like this are very important for us
to be able to learn from other jurisdictions and also other sectors as well.
Thank you for the flex on time.
Great. Thank you, Stephanie.
There is so much to share.
I think it's that's always the challenge of an hour of conversation.
But a first step in that and we'll unpack a little bit.
So thanks to you and Kerry for sharing just the big frame and all of the
kind of pieces, I think we're going to spend a couple of minutes kind of pulling apart.
I have a couple of questions for you both just to reflect on
that align with what you shared and maybe go a little bit deeper into a couple aspects.
I'll mention just I know that we've seen some questions pop through
in the Q&A and the chat, so keep them coming.
And I'm going to include some of the questions that have been shared
into what I'm offering to both of our colleagues to reflect on
because they were aligned with what's on our minds as well as we went into the conversation.
So I think first, one of the things that we
and I know I personally have been really curious about is why quality of life
as the kind of centerpiece or the North Star or the core of the focus for the framework.
And was there any deliberation in terms of how you really oriented towards that
as the centerpiece and were there other kind of directions that were in play
as you develop the approach?
So, yes, there were.
And I mean, this is part of the challenge.
I call this the hall of mirrors.
So while there are a lot of people active in this space,
it's often say the Department of Health, which is essentially creating a framework
which points up to health as the ultimate outcome, or it's the Department of Finance
that's saying, yeah, quality of life is well and good.
But it's really about prosperity at the center of things.
And so there's a lot of alignment in the kind of horizontal thinking.
But when you get to that sort of what are we driving towards, what's the big picture?
That was a bit trickier.
So we did have lots of negotiations and, you know, it's never going to be completely done.
But our sort of idea was that this this was, you know, you don't even though
poverty is an important determinant of health, you don't fix poverty
solely to achieve a health outcome.
You know, poverty is its own determinant of well-being.
And so there's continues to be an active dialogue in this space.
But in terms of quality of life versus, say, well-being,
we actually did public opinion research on that question, too.
Quality of life came out ahead.
Another sort of framing thing that is a bit of attention is, is this just another name
for social as distinct from environment and economic?
And you can see in our framework that that's not where we landed.
This quality of life framework brings in the environment and economy
in a sort of a different way that's more integrative, in my opinion.
So that that's kind of a bit of a a bit of a synopsis,
synopsis of many, many, many discussions.
Super helpful.
Stephanie, do you want to add anything or?
Sure. So it was that we were a little bit less implicated in those discussions
that landed the framework.
But in the course of pursuing implementation,
I think what we find is maybe I would say a couple of things.
The first is that by keeping the door open to the fact that it is evergreen,
I think there is this this this tension as we're rolling out internally.
Is it where we want it to be?
But in terms of the starting point, it's that we have quality of life.
So we're sticking to it for now.
But it is that for the other miss or the other departments
that are grounded in the work that they are they are pursuing,
they are they are proposing other centers, let's say.
Or it's that you have the framework, but you could have different centers.
So let's say they would advocate for a certain center
to say nothing of how I think in the environmental or sustainability space,
there is an expansion of it
that in some circles would be seen as like rival ring, rivaling
what the quality of life is supposed to capture,
which is essentially everything at a certain societal level.
So it's that I think you will have these this this this tension
between competing, competing framers, competing visions of the world.
It's kind of part and parcel of the exercise,
even if you think you've landed something for a little bit.
That's great. Yeah, I think we face the same tension.
But I think where we've come to, at least now, is how do we help
folks from very different points of view see themselves in different frames,
even if they have one orientation and understand it's all related
in terms of the intersections that you're both pointing out?
So I wanted to ask, I know this is a much deeper question than we can get to,
but any insights on how you approach kind of moving from big ideas
or concepts to more operational qualities of measurement,
all of the things that are in the framework that you have,
I think are really important, big ideas.
And then, you know, the quality of how do you make that concrete
in a way that's not burdensome and also feels like it's it's really orienting
to a core set of measures to be helpful in advancing that idea.
So I'm curious if you have any insights about how you approach that.
I think the mapping exercise that we did was sort of a bottom up version of that.
So what are we already measuring that matters?
But then there's sort of a top down approach to where you start from,
you know, what is the big picture, what's our North Star,
what does the evidence say about what we know matters?
And I think both of those things coming together is important
because we included some things in our framework that we didn't have existing
measures for, but also mapping the international landscape matters, too,
as I mentioned in that one example that I provided.
But I think there's sort of a you want to come at it from different perspectives
and try to sort of articulate where you want to be.
And then once you've got a shape to things, then you so so we included measures
in our frameworks that didn't exist.
And I think that's important because then we put in our next steps list.
OK, we have to go and figure it out now to measure that thing.
And so it was a sort of a separate step to say,
what do we think is important to have in the framework?
And then how are we going to measure it?
What's the definition?
And so that work was led by it has been led by Statistics Canada
versus the conceptual framing led by finance.
Right. OK.
I do think the the finance and stats
can work was the heavy lifting and the very first
foundational step to get to anywhere in our implementation work.
This is I think the first discussion that we have to get out of the way of,
oh, what is quality of life that's really nebulous?
It can mean anything.
And our answer is no, no, we have a framework.
There are 84 things we're saying it can mean for now.
And and yes, we might not have data sources for just about
or for all of them, but we're just about there.
But just having identified the indicators, of course,
is not at the end of the project.
That's where we're supposed to be helpful.
So it's like we are as CBS in the business of making the concept real.
So I had mentioned or maybe not in that my title is very long.
My division is results division in TVS.
It needs to go from concept to actual result.
But it could be that it could be that you're looking at,
I guess, different kinds of operationalization.
There is one way in which, oh, yes, just moving the needle on the
the indicators is what you are looking for.
But for us in the machinery of government, we
look at government initiatives on an initiative basis.
And for each, they are they are supposed to be able to say
what they will do for Canadians and to be able to to draw that link
to the quality of life framework.
So maybe that's a good plug for how as much as TVS provides
the like supports to be able to make that happen.
The expertise is not the policy expertise is not here.
The departments tell us how that's possible.
What makes sense, what logic models make sense.
We can only support them in that effort.
That's great. Yeah, that also so that relates to, you know,
a question I know is seeing coming from the audience as well.
And so can you use this language in your remarks about Canadians
seeing themselves in the frame or those those qualities of what the work is?
And I'm curious if you can try.
I know you were both speaking to the robust process of how you engaged
and got feedback and real, you know, work to begin dialogue.
But I'm hoping you can speak to what the level of awareness
and active engagement is in terms of the quality of life framework
or what you're hoping to see that evolve to for kind of the,
you know, normal folks or the folks, you know, across the country
in terms of their ownership or just their awareness of how that framework
is connected to the resources or policies that are, you know,
advancing from, you know, the government.
Kerry, I'll start if that's OK.
I it's a very interesting question, something that I didn't
manage to get out of my presentations, how in some ways
the quality of life file is very unusual for us.
We are not normally this outside facing.
We deal with we deal with the government and supporting the rest of government.
And so I think this question is one that we maybe are still reflecting on
in that we we want the we want the results.
We want the outcomes.
It is almost
maybe the sacrilegious to to those who are closer to the well-being work.
But if it doesn't, if it's not recognized as, you know,
the fruits of the quality of life approach, that could be that could be OK.
It is just that I think in our view, the socialization of the quality
of life framework is an important piece to making sure it stays around
and sets expectations so that the public, you know, demand that
the quality of life outcomes.
But you could end up in a place where the outcomes are achieved
without everyone knowing about the framework.
Yeah, I agree with that. Great point.
Gary, anything to add?
Yeah, I think this work has an element of participatory democracy
and people come to it from a lot of different channels.
And so we had a lot of these conversations early on, and people were starting from,
you know, sometimes they're starting from a population group that of interest.
Sometimes they're starting from the somatic area or what have you.
And so there was, you know, hundreds, hundreds of conversations
with people sort of having a slightly different version of of of their starting point.
And so I think I saw Chris Barrington Lee here.
So I'll give a shout out to work that he's been instrumental in leading,
which is kind of coalescing a community of practice outside of government,
of people, academics, well, actually government and outside of government.
So similar to the structure.
I think that you're building here that that that brings people
into the same conversation with each other.
And I think that's a really valuable contribution that it's, you know,
people are having individual conversations with government,
but it's really valuable for them to be talking together as well
and moving to to to sort of, you know, identify there's going to be some differences,
but also some shared areas of focus.
And that's really valuable to us if we can sort of coalesce around that.
Amazing. Thank you both.
I know, given time, I'm going to hand back to Elizabeth.
But just to say, you know, really appreciate your insights
and reflections on that and a lot more to learn as we go forward.
Thank you so much. Incredible nuts and bolts.
There's so much that we could dig into here.
And there were a number of questions that were coming up to about just kind of more
granular level detail on the quality of measurement, the sort of,
you know, the undergirding questions or data points within your five domains.
And so I do want to remind the audience that we dropped a link to the Quality of Life Hub.
When I first landed on this hub, I was totally blown away
by how much you all have put forth as available to the public.
And so I just want to thank you so much for that.
And thank you for giving us some of the behind the scenes kind of deliberations
and things that helped to really inform the development of all that.
To close us out, I'm going to turn to three U.S.
federal colleagues to just kind of quickly share some of the insights,
what struck them within the context of the work that they're currently doing
as part of this exchange.
So I'm going to turn first to Shannon, then to Sunil and then to Danielle.
So if you could quickly introduce yourself and share just a couple of minutes
to help close us out. Thank you.
Sure. I'm Dr.
Shannon Aravisu, I'm a sociologist and I'm working as a senior advisor
within the office of the chief data officer at the Department of Commerce.
And one of the things that really struck me about your work
is the fact that you have created a North Star for your country
and that you started from first principles around what are the factors
that contribute to national well-being, recognizing that there are many factors,
not just government interventions and programs and policies
that contribute to that well-being.
And so the fact that you created that wide umbrella for so many different
facets of society to fit into, I think, is something that is going to be
hugely instrumental for your success.
And I'm also noticing attention to, you know, change management principles
and coalition building and recognizing that this, you know, to move this forward
is going to require multiple sectors across society working together.
And you provided a framework for businesses to fit in, for nonprofits to fit in.
And I think that's really commendable and inspiring.
I'm so excited to dig in more and also to see how we can evolve
and adapt the current framework that Erin and McDonald and her team
is implementing at the moment.
So I'll pass it over to the rest of my federal government colleagues.
Yes, thank you.
So I'm Sunil Iyengar, director of the Office of Research and Analysis,
very much concerned with metrics and research at the National Endowment for the Arts.
And I'm just loving this discussion, resounding yes to everything Shannon said
and Elizabeth have said in terms of praise of this framework,
just why it resonates for us a quick minute.
So beyond the GDP framework, the NEA actually partners with the U.S.
Bureau of Economic Analysis to measure the arts contribution to GDP,
as do a lot of countries and I think Canada as well.
But we, too, have for years tried to really understand
some of these other benefits of the arts.
And we've we've done that through a couple of things I want to mention.
I'll just say that we actually have worked with,
have corresponded with our colleagues at Statistics Canada
because there's a convention coming up this summer,
the Association of Cultural Economics International.
We're the first time they're actually including a well-being focus,
health and well-being.
So we've actually created a symposium to talk more about this work,
arts and health and well-being measurement specifically.
But, you know, I liked what what Kerry said about objective
and subjective indicators flowing into each other, because let's just face it,
we don't have a lot of hard data at this time, I would submit
in terms of randomized control trials and that kind of those kinds of studies
on the arts direct relationship and causality in terms of causality
to some of the subjective well-being measures or some of the health measures
we constantly talk about.
So that's why we're trying to support research with other federal partners
like the National Institutes of Health on psychology, neuroscience, medical research
to support, you know, to get more of that data that you can then point to.
But I love the fact that the framework you created, as is the equitable
long term recovery resilience framework, is aspirational and starting
really with the theory and what the grounded theory of what these outcome areas are.
And then going in and hopefully having some extra data,
but creating new data where it doesn't exist.
So I'll just quickly say in closing that two aspects of the arts
and I'd love to see the arts referenced more visibly in such frameworks,
creativity and self-expression, which is an outcome area, which doesn't really
may slip between the cracks sometimes when we talk about
intermediate outcomes of well-being and, of course, social socialization.
I know social exchange is a big part of your framework, too.
But, you know, our Surgeon General just released a report, advisory
health advisory for the first time on isolation and the dangers of loneliness
and isolation, and we think the arts have a big role to play.
So we'll be working with the equitable long term recovery resilience framework
and hopefully do some more interagency working group efforts around arts,
health and civic infrastructure.
Thank you so much.
And Sunil, it's the perfect segue, because in order to get to this arts
and cultural, you need public transportation.
So Danielle Nelson, I work at the US Department of Transportation,
one of the nine modes, the federal trans administration.
And I was just really pleased to see the quality of life framework,
including under the environment sector, the walkable communities
and access to public transit.
And so we've been working very closely with our colleagues at Health
Human Services through what's called the Coordinated Council on Access Mobility.
It's a federal member council to improve human services, transportation access.
So just pleasant to be here today.
And I know we're short on time,
so we'll just stop there and pass it back over.
Thank you all so much.
I think you you really helped to illustrate the breadth of learning
that's possible through this kind of exchange.
So thank you.
And thanks to everyone who joined us today.
We will follow up with a recording for your access.
I know several folks were interested in that.
And we also are going to share an invite to our next learning community call,
which will be on June 20th.
So with this learning community, what we're trying to do is sort of pop open
the hood on state, local and federal policy initiatives
that are designed to foster equitable well-being.
So please stay tuned for that.
And thank you so much for being a part of today's conversation.
Take care, everyone.